it is very common
for women in particular and men to to
regret not having children later
it is very common most people most
people will not derive great meaning in
their lives from their careers most
people will derive great meaning from
their children but when you're in your
80s you can't depend on other 80 year
old friends
to look after you in the way that adult
children can and also you probably
aren't going to be able to depend on the
state either because that's the other
story in relation to
falling fertility
the welfare state is a Ponzi scheme it
always was right like when when the odd
age of pension was introduced when the
NHS was introduced we had a much younger
population on average we had much higher
birth rates
and no one ever expected
these things to become
I think six and six percent and seven
percent respectively of GDP it's already
clear that
State pensions the NHS and the whole
welfare state is not sustainable